tensions between Israel and Hamas is not
slowing down Palestine it's such a mess
right now that 400 people got killed in
a hospital where one side of saying
Israel did it the other day saying Hamas
did it President Biden had to go to meet
with Netanyahu and have a conversation
even in a meeting he says well with the
recent events that happened we're pretty
confident that it was Hamas that did it
but we're looking into it it's that you
didn't do it like that's what Joe Biden
said to Netanyahu in his face which was
kind of interesting and then to the
point 2.2 million people were talking
about the Gaza Strip one of the most
densely populated places in the world
755,000 people live within a square mile
no food no water no electricity no
hospital supplies since tonight they've
had none of that they're being pushed
down imagine the viruses the sickness
all of this stuff is taking place at the
same time Russia's now getting involved
hezbollah's commenting Iran's been
involved us is sending 2,000 troops that
are ready to go out it's just an
absolute mess so here's what we wanted
to do a number came out a report if
you're looking at the screen showing
only 4 in 10 18 to2 29 year olds have a
negative view of Hamas if you look at
this chart you'll notice that when you
look at 18 to 29 year olds 10% of them
10 one out of 10 views them positively
why do they view them positively Hamas
positively where do these 18 to 29y Old
spend most time with at universities are
professors speaking positively about
Hamas is this why so many billionaires
are taking money that they're no longer
putting in universities publicly saying
we're no longer supporting University of
Pennsylvania or Harvard or Yale or many
of these other places what is this all
about why are they you in this way so we
wanted to make a video specifically to
talk about the history of Hamas
Hezbollah and Isis little bit of
al-Qaeda so you know how they got
started what their motives are what
their vision is and are they a terrorist
organization categorically they are why
are they a terrorist organization I
think we need to take a deep dive to
learn about their
histories
so if you give value out of this video
give it a thumbs up and subscribe to the
channel so let's get right into it I
want to start off by posing a question
for you to be thinking about when does a
political party become a terrorist
organization when do Freedom Fighters a
lot of people are saying I'm doing this
for Freedom when do Freedom Fighters
stop being Heroes and become Killers
let's take a look at Hamas first so what
is Hamas Hamas is a spin-off the
Palestinian branch of the Muslim
Brotherhood in the late 80s the islamist
militant group Hamas took over the Gaza
Strip after de feeding its rival
political party fat in elections in 2006
its rival party fat which dominates the
Palestine Liberation Organization PLO
and rules in the West Bank has renounced
violence so again just to isolate these
two here Hamas Prov violence fat were
not violence okay we have a different
way of going about presenting our
argument to others okay so hamas's
founder was shik Ahmed Yassin a
Palestinian cleric who became an
activist in local branches of the Muslim
Brotherhood after dedicating his early
life to Islamic scholarship in Cairo
Yasin established Hamas as the
brotherhood's political arm in Gaza in
December of 1987 following the outbreak
of the first intifa a Palestinian
Uprising against Israeli occupation of
the West Bank Gaza and East Jerusalem at
the time hamas's purpose was to counter
Palestinian Islamic Jihad P another
organization whose commitment to
violence resisting Israel threaten to
draw Palestinian support away from the
Brotherhood in 1988 Hamas established
and Lish its Charter calling for the
destruction of Israel and the
establishment of an Islamic society in
historic Palestine and they called it
we're going to bring back Shar to here
so that is their Vision we talked about
this in a previous video as well to
continue in what observers called an
attempt to moderate its image Hamas
presented a new document in 2017 that
accepted an interim Palestinian State
along the green line border established
before the 6- day war but that still
refused to recognize Israel Hamas first
employed suicide bombing in April of
1993 5 months before PLO leader Yasir
Arafat and Israeli Prime Minister Yak
Rabin signed the Oslo cord then finally
the US in
1997 and the European Union designated
Hamas a terrorist organization because
of its armed resistance against Israel
which has included suicide bombing and
rocket attack so this category for Hamas
happened in 97 today Iran is one of
hamas's biggest benefactors contributing
weapons and training Iran currently
provides some hundred million annually
to Hamas p and other Palestinian groups
designated as terrorist organization by
the US Hamas has fired rockets and
mortars into Israel since the group took
over the Gaza Strip in the mid 2000s the
group has also carried out incursions
into Israeli territory killing and
kidnapping soldiers and civilians now
let's take a look at their violent
history to see what they've done on the
past before prior to his 2023 conflict
Hamas and Israel had their deadliest
fighting in 2021 when Hamas fired
Rockets into Israel following weeks of
tensions between Palestinians and
Israelis in Jerusalem and during the
11-day conflict Hamas and P fired more
than 4,000 Rockets from Gaza killing 10
Israeli civilians injuring more than 300
others and Hamas reportedly coordinated
with the irgc and lebanon's Hezbollah
again irgc Iran Hezbollah during the
fighting and used so-called suicide
drones along with its usual arsenal of
less precisive missiles the United
States and Egypt broker a ceasefire to
the conflict so now let's talk about
hamas's hostages in addition to hamas's
surprise attack on October 7 Israel's
military said at least 199 people had
been taken hostage by Hamas officials
from the US and other countries are
determining if their citizens are among
the captives you're hearing numbers
around 250 people and even recently
Hamas came out and said listen if
they're figuring out a way to do
ceasefire they're talking to Israel we
will negotiate to give some of the
children and woman hostages up if you
cease fire they announced this I think
on Wednesday or Thursday they made that
announcement so now we've talked about
Hamas let's not talk about Hezbollah and
what hezbollah's history is because I
have some history with Hezbollah because
when I was in Iran I remember what
Hezbollah was doing to the streets how
many people feared Hezbollah this is
hezbollah's history Hezbollah means the
party of God is what they consider
themselves Hezbollah is a Shiites Muslim
political party and militant group based
in Lebanon where its extensive security
apparatus political organization and
Social Services Network have fostered
its reputation as a state within a state
so what is Hezbollah they were founded
in the chaos of 15E Lebanese Civil War
and Iran's back group is driven by its
opposition to Israel and its resistance
to Western influence in the Middle East
with its history carrying out Global
terrorist attacks part of Hezbollah and
in some cases the entire organization
have been designated as a terrorist
group by the United States also in 1997
and by many countries now when it comes
down to their military strength in the
recent years long-standing alliances
with Iran and Syria have transformed
Hezbollah into an increasingly effective
military force one that experts say
would pose a challenge in the event of
new fighting against its longtime enemy
Israel just to put this in perspective
so you can look at it with numbers Hamas
is total roughly 40,000 soldiers is what
Hamas has Hezbollah is 150,000 nearly
four times as powerful as Hamas by the
way Israel is 400,000 so you may say wow
Israel is massive not that much bigger
than Hezbollah if you think about it 150
to 400 it is 2 and 1 half times but it's
not astronomically a bigger military
organization Hezbollah still has a lot
of Firepower behind their army that they
have let me continue with lebanon's
failing at the same time Hezbollah
officials and other leaders in Lebanon
are facing public discontent as the
nation verges on failure and hezbollah's
political power could be shrinking The
History of hezbollah's Violence emerged
during a Lebanon 15year Civil War which
broke out in 1975 when long simmering
discontent over the large armed
Palestinian presence in the country
reached a boiling point they were a
group of Shiites influenced by the
Theocratic government in Iran the
Region's major Shi government which came
to power in 1979 this is when I was born
in 78i comes in around late January
early uh February Hezbollah take over
Iran and it's a complete different
country complete different Revolution
complete different way of living when
that took place and obviously when this
happened in 1979 Hezbollah took arms
against the Israeli occupation so many
time when you hear Hezbollah you'll hear
Iran Iran's funding Iran irgc you'll
keep hearing these phrase what ises that
really mean seeing an opportunity to
expand its influence in Arab states Iran
and its irgc which stands for Islamic
revolutionary guard Corp provided funds
and training to the budding militia
which adopted the name Hezbollah meaning
the party of God it earned a reputation
for extremist militancy due to its
frequent clashes with rival shed
militias such as attacks on foreign
targets including the
1983 suicide bombing of Barracks housing
us and French troops in Beirut in which
more than 300 people died they were
behind it hbas became a viola to Iran
bridging Shiites Arab Persian divides as
tan established proxies throughout the
Middle East remember how earlier we
talked about hamas's Charter what they
stand for this is hezbollah's Manifesto
let me read it to you 1985 Manifesto
they vowed to expel Western powers from
Lebanon called for the destruction of
the Israeli State and pledge allegiance
to Iran's supreme leader it also
advocated an Iran inspired islamist
regime regime but emphasized that the
Lebanese people should have the freedom
of self-determination so again Hamas the
enemy Western Civilization Israel same
exact thing with the manifesto that
Hezbollah has they're very much aligned
on who the enemy is the enemy of an
enemy is a friend you know that whole
thing this this is when they're kind of
like saying you hate those guys and
those guys we do too let's become
friends that's where they're at so aside
from the manifesto the group reiterated
its commitment to his destruction of the
Israeli state in its 2009 Manifesto 24
years later Manifesto same thing the
enemy is still Israel Hezbollah has been
blamed for attacks on Jewish and Israeli
targets abroad including the 1994 car
bombings of a Jewish Community Center in
Argentina which killed 85 people and the
bombings of the Israeli Embassy in
London so so you know some people said
well maybe if Israel you know withdraws
and they leave the tensions will go down
even after Israel officially withdrew
from Southern Lebanon in 2 it continued
to clash with Hezbollah that conflict
didn't stop periodic conflict between
Hezbollah and Israeli forces established
into a month-long war in 2006 during
which Hezbollah launched thousands of
rockets into Israeli territory and in
August 2021 Hezbollah fired more than a
dozen rockets in response to Israel's
air strikes in Lebanon it was the first
time the group claimed responsibility
for Rockets fired into Israel since 2006
Israel Hezbollah War analyst and
Brigadier General retired Assaf Oran of
the Israeli Institute for National
Security study says Hezbollah possesses
a larger arsenal of artillery than most
Nations enjoy and a 2018 report from the
center for strategic and International
Studies called it the world's most
heavily armed non-state actor Hezbollah
meanwhile critics say hezbollah's
existence violates un Security Council
resolution 1559 adopted in 20 4 which
called for all Lebanese militias to
disband and disarm and in October of
2019 Hezbollah became a target of mass
protest government mismanagement and
years of slow growth had saddled Lebanon
with one of world's highest public debt
burdens at 150% of its gross domestic
product so obviously a lot of people are
sitting there saying well look if if
Hamas is doing what they're doing if
Israel attacks little too much Hezbollah
is going to get involved to back him up
and did we see a sign of that that's
exactly what happened following the
October assault on Israel by Hamas
Hezbollah had f shells across the Israel
Lebanon Border in a show of what the
group's leaders call solidarity with
Hamas it's like a announcement hey just
so everybody knows we have their back
Hamas and several hezbollah's militias
reportedly attempted to infiltrate
Israel Iran and Hezbollah likely advised
and trained Hamas on how to attack
Israel experts say though Hamas
maintains that neither was involved in
planning his 2023 operations this has
been written about all over the place
Wall Street Journal that Iran was
involved in this attack that Hamas had
on Israel so so far we've talked about
Hamas and we've talked about Hezbollah
how about Isis and or how big are they
today are they still as powerful as they
were before let's talk about the history
of Isis Isis is a salafi jihadist group
that has conducted and inspired
terrorist attacks worldwide resulting in
thousands killed or injured in 2004 an
Iraqi extremist Network led by Abu musab
Al Zara merged with Al-Qaeda to form
isis's predecessor group called al-Qaeda
in Iraq so in 2013 al-Qaeda in Iraq
changed its name name two Isis and in
2014 the group separated from Al-Qaeda
declared itself a caliphate and took
over vast swats of territory in Iraq and
Syria so if you're asking a question I I
don't know what a caliphate is here's
the definition of caliphate it's a
political religious State comprising the
Muslim Community and the lands and
peoples under its Dominion in the
centuries following the death of prophet
Muhammad now in 2019 an International
Coalition ejected Isis from its last
stronghold in Syria although the group
continues to operate clandestinely there
and in Iraq despite losing many of its
leaders in its territory Isis remains
capable of conducting Insurgent
operations in Iraq and Syria while
overseen at least 19 branches and
networks in Africa Asia and Europe and
by the way when you look at size tier
one terrorist organization some would
say is Hezbollah 150,000 of them right
tier two is Hamas tier three when you
look at Isis it's only roughly between 8
to 16,000 and their operating areas is
primarily in Northern and Eastern Syria
Syria and Northern Iraq Isis tactics and
targets isis uses targeted killings IED
attacks ambushes military style assaults
kidnapping and suicide attacks in Iraq
and Syria the group also encourages
adherence worldwide to conduct
operations in their own countries and
Isis mostly attacks military targets and
civilian Defense Forces government
Personnel infrastructure in addition to
foreign a workers and civilians who Isis
perceives are working against it or are
opposed to the interpretation of Islamic
law so if now you're wondering you're
saying well Hezbollah got a terrorist
group designation so did Hamas did Isis
ever get that they did in 2004 the US
state department designated Al-Qaeda
isis's predecessor as a foreign
terrorist organization in December of
2004 a designation that remains in
effect for Isis till today so even
though this isn't 2004 and it still
stands till today you may be asking well
when's the last time they even did an
attack wasn't that like pre-trump did we
have anything that happened because
during Trump Trump everybody forgot
about Isis Isis was very big during
Obama but I want to give you four the
different attacks they had recently one
of them is July 3rd of 2016 they
attacked Baghdad Iraq They carried out a
suicide car bombing that killed more
than 200 people January 16 2019 in Syria
they conducted a suicide bombing outside
of a restaurant killing 15 people
including four Americans July 19 2021
Baghdad Iraq they conducted a suicide
bombing in a crowded Market on the eve
of AD Al ad holiday killing at least 35
people and injuring more than 60 and
last but not least January of last year
2022 in Syria Isis attacks Garian prison
leading to a weak long Siege on the
facility and surrounding neighborhoods
killing more than 100 prison guards and
400 Isis detainees so so if you look at
this chart you'll notice a trend two of
them are Iraq two of them are Syria
three of them are suicide bombing so
again going back to what their style is
suicide bombing Iraq Syria to to finish
up the topic here on Isis and comparing
Al-Qaeda I want to give give you a
little bit more context before we move
on Al-Qaeda and its affiliate remain a
threat to the US Homeland while the
Islamic State danger is more to the
stability of the Middle East and US
interest overseas much of their rivalry
between the to Al-Qaeda and Isis
involves a competition for affiliates
with both trying to spread their model
in al-qaeda's case to ensure its
operational relevance for now the
Islamic State focus is primarily on Iraq
and Syria and to a lesser degree on the
states in the Muslim World particularly
in Libya now in the United States and in
Europe it may Inspire lone wolves but
it's not directing its resources to
attack in these areas and security
services are prepared for the threat
Al-Qaeda is weaker and less Dynamic than
the Islamic State but the former remains
more focus on attacking the United
States and its Western allies so they're
not targeting Syria and Iraq they're
targeting us so so now somebody may be
watching this and and let's just say
you're Palestinian let's say you're a
Muslim you're watching like oh my God
what's this all about how dare you put
this how about all the things that
Americans have done you know how about
the fact that you guys had a drone
strike in August of 2021 and you were
targeting somebody but you missed your
target but you killed 10 innocent people
what about that huh us has done that and
it's happened under every President
Biden we had collateral damage under
Trump and we had collateral damage under
Obama was trying to Target this and all
of a sudden they target they missed the
opportunity totally get it there there's
blood on many different countries hands
including Us's but there's a difference
and you have have to be reasonable
enough to ask this question when's the
last time you heard Americans doing
suicide bombing when now Americans
believe in God we also believe in God I
believe in God but when's the last time
you hear things like that there is a
reason why these guys get categorically
they get designated as a terrorist
organization because they're willing to
give up their lives to kill people that
they think is the enemy you can sit
there and say Pat you're out of line how
about the time of America no problem not
sitting here telling you everybody's you
know everyone's guilty and we're
innocent and all this stuff but you have
to be able to reason and say yeah it's
kind of a good point man they don't
really have that reputation for doing
that maybe folks from these three places
do but Americans do not all right so
let's talk about update on Israel
Palestine the last week here I've been
asking two questions number one how did
Israel not know that Hamas was going to
attack and they're setting up a facility
to learn how to come and get hostages
how does Israel not know you brag about
having the best intelligence in the
world mad and you mean to tell me you
missed this one little bit weird valid
question then the other one that I asked
earlier and we've been talking about
this on podcast with Vinnie Adam and and
Tom is if Palestinians are so great and
they're so innocent and they're such
fantastic peaceful people why isn't
Egypt willing to take them they're their
neighbors they know them better than
anybody else both questions gets a group
to say that's the right question to ask
terrible question or they say that's the
wrong question how dare you say that
about Palestine because they know if
they leave Palestine is Israel is going
to take over Gaza really yes okay fine
you give that argument but my question
isn't about if they leave my question is
a lot of people are trying to leave why
is Egypt saying no you can't come here
what's Egypt's incentive of keeping
people there so people say well now that
that report of Egypt reporting and
giving it to Israel is not true let me
show you what we got here September 20th
intelligence report warned of the
possibility that Hamas would launch
rocket strikes into Israel over the
course of multiple days the New York
Times reported us officials then the
second report from the cie dated October
5th 2 days before Hamas carried out its
attack warned of an increased
probability of violence from Hamas this
is twice one September 28th one October
5th from CIA is where time this is not
like it's hypothetical New York Post
article then a source familiar with the
intelligence told CNN the military
friction in the Israel Gaza region is
nothing out of the normal while another
official familiar with the reports
describ them to be times as routine and
meanwhile Iran is sitting there saying
you you know what you guys crossed the
line we have to now intervene and what
does that really mean well either
Hezbollah is going to get involved
they're going to get involved they got
many different ways to get involved and
remember tier three Isis 8 to 16,000
Hamas 40,000 hisbah
150,000 what happens if they get
involved it's a whole different story if
they choose to get involved now I want
to put the start for you to be thinking
about when it comes on to the hospital
with 400 people that got killed in the
hospital whose fault is it Israel is it
Hamas when I was living in Iran during
the time when it's so funny my dad's
telling my wife today on what time I was
born I was born a little bit after
midnight on October 18th my mom's water
broke my dad's taking her to the
hospital there's curfew their past
curfew they get held up with
semi-automatic weapons saying what are
you doing driving a car when the streets
are empty says my wife's water broke
she's bre pregnant they escort me to the
hospital and then I'm born literally
past midnight on the 18th watch the
story an event happens in Iran called
Cinema Rex fire Cinema Rex fire cinema
cinema Rex name fire Cinema Rex was in a
city called abadan abadan is the where a
place where all these oil refineries are
okay there's a police station right
across the street from Cinema Rex when
this happens Hezbollah everybody said
this is the work of saak they shut down
the entire movie theater 400 people
couldn't leave the movie theater they
CAU the place on fire pregnant women
kids died imagine you're burning you
can't get out cuz they locked up the
place it's called the cinema Rex fire
okay I'm sure you've seen the story
they're posting the article all over the
page while I'm talking to you Hezbollah
Andi convinced Iranians that reash sha
palavi did it with the help of Sak Sak
was his M so our CIA their Sak they were
trained by mad and CIA again they're
intelligent group right you know what
ends up happening to everybody in Iran
how dare this cold hearted billionaire
King monarchy spend 25 quar of a billion
putting the celebration of 2500 years of
Iran this guy's so rich and we're so
poor and you killed 400 innocent people
boom escalated escalated escalated
everybody said the king did it
Revolution millions of people in the
streets it was the biggest Revolution
ever that took place KET with none of
the major four components that you need
for a revolution you know who woni won
the Sha had to get in a helicopter
Escape get in a plane and leave do you
know what happened a couple months later
year later reports came back that fire
was never the Sha it was somebody that
was part of's camp that did it guess
what it's too late Revolution already
happened what's the moral of the story I
don't know if Israel is behind it or not
and I don't know if Hamas is behind it
or not all I know is whoever is behind
it that did this intentionally there's a
strategy behind it to put the blame on
the other person to increase emotions
possibly yours and mine and say how dare
they did something like that to get what
they want whatever that they want is we
don't know yet it may take us 6 12 18 24
months to really find out who was behind
it but don't jump to conclusion taking
one side or the other because it favors
your argument sit back a little bit and
let's really see what happens I like
what Joe Biden said today when he's
sitting across Netanyahu he says our
intelligence tells us Hamas was behind
it not you obviously we'll find out but
our intelligence said Hamas is behind
look at the way he's given the answer
leaving it out but he's saying we have
your back but we're going to find out
that's the right approach to take cuz we
still don't know who was really behind
what happened with this hospital so so
look we can do a whole different video
on world or three here soon on how many
times we got close to and how to prevent
prevent it that's going to come up here
soon but I want to give you a final F to
be thinking about one of the biggest
challenges you and I have as human
beings because we're emotional beings
robots don't have this challenge you and
I do we have something called emotions
we have something called life
experiences we have something called
beliefs religion who you believe in what
you believe in political all this stuff
that we have right and our loyalty
typically is to our parents Our Heritage
our background
these guys can never do anything wrong
as a parent I've been in the office
where my kids were at fault and I'm
sitting there saying you PID a price
what is his uh you know price he's going
to be suspended totally get it you pay
the price okay here's what we're going
to do we're going to have a conversation
and then if I think it's too much I'll
have the private conversation with the
principal but if I think it's right it's
right and there's been times where I've
been in a place where I've watched the
punishments went way too much and I've
said I don't think I'm good with this
punishment did you guys look at the tape
so we have to be fair there some parents
are like no my kids are never wrong he's
an angel and it's a lie because when I
was a kid there were many times I was
wrong okay and I know I was wrong as a
kid just like yourself what's the moral
of the story let's do our best to not
join the jump to conclusion Community
just because it validates your argument
or my argument we're all guilty every
once in a while now sitting here telling
you I'm an angel or you're an angel all
I'm saying during times like this where
emotions goes from zero to let's you
know go to war and do this let's kind of
pump the braks and let's not jump to
conclusion the only suggestion I got for
everybody the goal is to prevent people
from dying that's the goal the goal is
for people to live their lives and the
goal is to hold people accountable who
are doing things that is not appropriate
and they're taking people's lives but
before we jump to conclusion let's see
who's behind it let's do some research
and then once we know and if you're
right salute to you if you're wrong hey
I was wrong totally okay I'm okay being
wrong and I'm okay being right I'm more
interested in finding out the truth not
being right or wrong that's my job
anyways hopefully that gives you a
little bit of insight having said that
we did a video as a middle eastern
myself I wanted to find out who were the
angriest people in the world and I don't
know if you've ever seen the study or
not as an Armenian we were ranked third
I'm like wow now that's all starting to
make sense and as an ass Syrian Armenian
from Iran when you see the ranking
you'll see why but it tells you a little
bit about the history why certain
regions are angrier than others if
you've not seen this clip click here to
watch it take care everybody bye-bye
bye-bye